good afternoon everybody Welcome to what
you need to know gma3 and it's Friday
Eve Amy robach and TJ Holmes reunite on
Good Morning America after news breaks
of their secret relationship
who's looking forward to the weekend uh
me yeah yes meanwhile Amy's husband
Andrew Shu deletes all traces of Amy
from his Instagram Andrew and I are in
our second marriage we have a blended
family we have step children Ex-Wives
ex-husbands it all started on Wednesday
when the Daily Mail published pics of
Amy and TJ packing on the PDA all over
New York in recent weeks but over at GMA
it was business as usual for TJ at the 9
A.M anchor desk yes Roblox is not here
Dr Ashton not here stuck with me folks
oh just take it in eat it up right
tonsil
um but yes those two are on the side but
they are working today yeah Amy may not
have been in studio Wednesday but she
was back on Thursday
and while they didn't address the
chatter directly they did say they're
ready for the weekend it's Friday Eve
who's looking forward to the weekend uh
me yeah yes of course of course we are
welcome everybody the dma3 what you need
to know always good to see you and if
you look closely you'll notice that
neither Amy nor TJ are wearing wedding
rings eagle-eyed fans noticed Amy
ditched hers back in October but TJ was
known to wear his on the show in fact he
was wearing it yesterday all right folks
welcome to gma3 minus two ain't that
something as for their Partners we've
learned both TJ and Amy split from their
spouses though we don't have a timeline
Amy's married to 90s heartthrob Andrew
shoe who played Billy Campbell on
Melrose Place
I agree with you we can't afford it
forget it if it's something that makes
you happy then you deserve it
since 2010 TJ's been married to Mary Lee
fiberg an attorney who's also chief of
staff at Jay-Z's Rock Nation they share
a daughter and TJ's dad to two kids from
a previous relationship
on Wednesday in the wake of news
spreading about Amy and TJ's romance
both journalists deleted their Instagram
accounts and Andrew he removed all pics
of Amy from his
keeping the romance alive in any
relationship well maybe it's a challenge
these days just a little bit sometimes
and while we don't know when Amy and TJ
went from colleagues to something more
and ET Source notes that they've kept it
professional on set even when The Vibes
are fun and sometimes flirty TJ isn't
that your favorite song
he always gets into the holiday spirit
why do I tell you things in confidence
as for Amy and TJ's special bond this is
the Platinum party at the palace and
yeah thank you so it's nice alliteration
there our source says it's not exactly
surprising to their co-workers who've
watched their connection grow over the
years
[Music]
thank you